[Applaudissements]
alors est-ce qu'on parlait de ma bile as
tout vouloir relayer dans tes peines
puisque ça vous ferait payer à la belote
dans la salle passage à cette occasion
lui pose la question et on parlera aussi
du livre parce qu'elle m'a fait une
petite dédicace alors vous jean michel
apparemment vous l'aimé beaucoup
oui donc j'aime beaucoup évidemment d'un
point de vue amicales oui je serais
content d'un point de vue esthétique oui
at-elle tuellement non jeudi les très
maline donc elle dit toujours ce qu'elle
ce qui va faire un peu le buzz mais
c'est pas vraiment ce qu'elle pense donc
je trouve c'est faux donc on va faire le
tour des photos mc vous trouvez mais ces
jeunes présentent devant matthieu
delormeau la sepa jean michel aulas
espère évidemment le meilleur je vous
souhaite bien et c'est pour ça que j'ai
pas ce que je vous ai de bh vous
souhaite voir faire d'autres choses que
tout jouable au chômage c'est ça des
indes autre chose qu'être ainsi que
voulez vous je suis vieux moi je suis
bien j'ai pas tournage ma chérie mais
ici la retraite mois à babou l'a mis là
on aime comme vous êtes vrai j'aime
j'aime le côté alors attendez là vous
allez entendre quelqu'un parler pour ne
rien dire
20h36 ils adorent mais vous allez voir à
la fin syrie qu'est-ce qu'il a dilué
vous êtes drôle vous avez des propos
concis et vous savez rebondir sur toutes
les situations avec humour j'aime
beaucoup ce que vous faites
mais alors elle voudrait pour n'est pas
la question oui j'ai loupé cette raison
que j'aimerais le voit à la voir
peut-être revenir de temps en temps ça
veut dire que le problème c'est qu'à la
fin de sa réponse tu suis un peu
l'occasion mais ça thomas attention un
jour alors bien méfiez-vous 2000 et sur
tous les dossiers
mais j'aime beaucoup aussi sur twitter
est-ce que je suis sur twitter
de ligue 1 quand il suit quelqu'un sur
twitter un lien qui le suit vraiment
dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
avec son iphone à ce qui suit le gaz
chez fido je suis nabila sur twitter
sabbatique merci très sympathique je
vais demander à rokhaya juste avant ils
demandèrent si je déjà un petit peu de
mémoire ou encore will vernet oui moi
vous manque et nabila je trouve que ce
serait bien que vous reveniez j'ai envie
que vous soyez là vous aviez des
interventions l'une est revenue phare il
avait des fulgurances
quand est-ce que vous revenez nous voir
tous maintenant vous finissez les
phrases mais robert vous vouliez dire un
truc sur le libre également ben oui vous
intéressant rives nabila est inclassable
vous rendez hommage à cyril en disant
qu'il a été le premier à avoir l'audace
de vous prendre comme coralie que ce
n'est pas évident à l'époque mais dont
je trouve que ce serait très bien de
boucler la boucle et de revenir à cette
voie la morale sonde avec huit heures
isabelle morini ce mot alors moi je suis
entièrement pour le retour de nabila
elle le sait et contrairement à toi jean
michel je pense qu'on est qu'au début et
qu'il ya vraiment une partie de la ville
un kappa est exploité c'est juste parle
pas du physique un jeu par les intérêts
et qui est vraiment mérites de la fcsq
c'est ici que s'adapter à ça fait sept
ans que les gens dit nabila se finit
elle est là depuis 2010 à nabila et elle
continue mais c'est vrai mais chaque
année on entend voilà c'est saison alors
femme fatale elle dit quoi
j'ai adoré ce mois ci mais pas trop le
t-shirt mais j'étais moi j'étais devant
ma télé qu'on habille la été
chroniqueuse je suis arrivé ya pas très
longtemps donc j'ai pas eu la chance de
faire cette émission avec toi et je te
trouvais parfaite extrêmement fraîche
extrêmement pertinentes et je trouve que
nabila et thomas d'ailleurs ils ont eu
cette intelligence de parfaitement capté
la société la génération et ont tiré
profit
très intelligemment ils ont capté la
société joly hm
ici tu es jolie vos divers
attention est toujours 25 ans ça fait
quoi comment l'adversaire crise d'ado
c'est là qu'on ait le sens interdit sur
ma porte et a pas droit de retrait rien
à [ __ ] hockey m'en fiche d'accord je
n'ai pas en contrôle histoire-géo
gelabale des stellistes et j'ai attendu
et l'autre sans déconner ça nous a fait
une crise d'ado ce qu'est dallas est là
dans le calme et vous quand même
et vous vous avez quel âge a dit la
pareille 25 ans également 6e des
personnalités l'impression que ça fait
50 ans qu'on est moi j'ai l'impression
que ça fait ça fait dix ans que je sais
que je suis dans le kent mais c'est vrai
paris 25 oct j'ai 30 ans on tombe ça va
et au 31 la fleur de l'âge et on a
beaucoup qui sont dans la fleur de l'âge
outils mais ils sont un petit peu fané
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est concerné par sa taille et sa
chérie non mais nabila ne laisse
personne indifférent évidemment comme
beaucoup de gens autour de cette table à
la sa place parce que qu'on les aime ou
qu'on déteste on aime la regarde et on
aime écouter donc forcément elle doit
revenir dans tpm p non parce que ça
manger que des bons souvenirs avec nabil
a donc évidemment je serais heureux
qu'il revienne mais moi j'aime bien
aussi voir thomas et voir comment ce
sens a dit loeb à un des seul truc qui
m'a plu c'est qu'on découvre thomas dans
la télé réalité et je suis sûr qu'il ya
des choses à offrir un point de vue et
j'aime bien de voir aussi une fois toute
fraude à la table il n'y en a pas pour
l'instant ils sont toujours collés l'un
à l'autre
ouais je pense qu'il peut y perdre au
goutte à reclasser de coiffure et bien
cette voiture et bien vous allez le
retenir ça on retrouve toucheront pas se
trouvent les fondamentaux du métier un
bordel me revenir même si jean-michel
n'est pas la table un jour peut-être
c'est vrai quand vous êtes posé la
question parce qu'on vous manquent pas
mais vous manquez beaucoup enfin c'était
cité l'expérience de hausse et voilà
c'est sûr que ça manque
alors quoi je vous dire je serais
vraiment moi je vous dis le problème
qu'hier c'est que j'engage tout le monde
sur la tête de ma mère quand je fais
l'étape de tmp
on dirait que fait l'étape de mariage
j'ai serré parce que maintenant elle a
plein nombre lui faut pas le mettre avec
lui lui non c'est le mardi parce que le
mardi il a inscrit mercredi quand ils
vont pas être à la table de l'autre
parce qu'il ya des gens de la photo de
rentrée qui sont toujours pas passés
c'est vrai alors le monde ne passera pas
cette année ça hypocrite
c'est sur les dix prochaines années en
fait les séries bioéthique la photo de
rentrer si les gens vous allez voir sous
les 10 prochaines années
d'accord donc ça peut arriver là le
royaume comme dans rue89 renvoie là
c'est les gens qui vont se succéder
autour de cette table et bien sûr on
n'en sera que plus joyeux alors est ce
que vous avez envie de la bile arvier
nous paraissent que oui à 46% à 54
c'est plus que partagés
[Musique]